not a lot of people remember or know
that the Bush administration actually
wanted you to join the Federal Reserve
Board of Governors you declined and but
today we're seeing central bank action
at its best actually
credibility at its worst for the Swiss
National Bank what do you make of this
move well I'm not surprised at all by
this move and and the reason is because
of the sinking euro you know they the
euro has gone down from about 142 we
know around 115 it might go down even
more and basically essentials I'm not
going to I'm not going to tie my ship to
a sinking boat you know so really what
they're doing is revaluing it I really
don't think this has terrible
international consequences I think it's
almost entirely due to the Euro sinking
if the euro had stayed around 130 you
would not see this Swiss bank action
professor was this also an anticipation
of more action a move by Mario Draghi on
the 22nd coming up yeah I mean I think
that you know the market is discounting
a healthy round of QE by the European
Central Bank you know Drive he's kind of
smiling at the fall of the exchange rate
you know I've called for the fall of the
euro for a long time I was always
puzzled how it stood up there at one 35
40 for so long with a sinking economy
but finally we are getting that move I
think that move in the Euro downward is
going to produce a better 2015 for the
European economy than many people
project right now and I think Draghi
wants to bring it down to 110 we've
heard talk of parity you know certainly
that's possible I don't think maybe he
wants it to go quite down that far but
that's the reason for the central bank
move in Switzerland anticipation of
Draghi and the the 20%
declined that we've already seen in the
euro